this is an historic vote for a number of
reasons not least because it's the first
time that turkey has had a runoff it's
the first time that turkey has had a
gone to the second uh
the second round and obviously this was
the toughest challenge that president
erdogan has ever faced in his career
he's been in power either do you speak
English in
it's difficult because we're also being
moved on by the police but there is
clear abject and joy in this area anyway
about the result
president erdogan was very close in the
first round
the reality in reality
in reality he's getting a lot of his
votes from very religious people
conservative people like the lady who's
just walked past us because he appealed
to the right wing and the religious vote
in his celebration speech just now
he pointed out and he has done regular
times during the campaign about how he
felt the Western media in particular was
um was very biased against him how they
were tilting things against him how they
were basically egging on the electorate
to vote against him in reality the cast
was very much set here the guy was very
much set here in Turkey erdogan over the
past two decades has basically cracked
down massively on descent he's jailed
journalists and any opposition
politicians who've really become very
dangerous to his position and even the
international monitors from the first
round indicated that although the days
voting in the first round appeared to be
free and fair the scales were so badly
and excessively tilted against the
opposition by
erdogan and his parties the AK party's
dominance of the media he's basically
controls or influenced most media
outlets for instance a short serving the
lead-up for the first round show but he
got 80 more air time than his rival
camel collector rollu but the scales
were very much tilted in his favor we
spoke to him in that first round and we
found a man who was very definitely not
at all worried about securing this third
Victory he was extremely calm he was
extremely confident he he did deals with
um a key nationalist group a person who
he felt uh held some a percentage of the
votes but really he was pandering to
that nationalist rhetoric as did
chemical
he also swung very much to the right and
this second runoff has been marred by
extremely negative campaigning by both
very
anti-refugee sentiment was whipped out
by both particularly by the opposition
with campaign Billboards plastered all
around Istanbul that we saw saying
syrians will go and both candidates
promising that they would send back
Syrian refugees millions of which have
taken refuge in this country and some of
whom have lived here for the best part
of a decade so there whatever happens
now
whatever happens now turkey has got some
serious issues and one of them is going
to be sorting the economy an economy
which is absolutely smashed to bits
an economy which is uh flailing with
inflation running very very high
inflation at one stage towards the end
of the year last year was running at
officially more than 80 percent
[Music]
many people complaining about how uh
inflation has doubled triples quadrupled
prices now those problems are still here
no matter that erdogan has won this this
historic Victory we understand from
people within the presidential Circle
that he was already preparing his
victory speech hours before the actual
announcement and the celebrations
started happening many people in this
country don't believe the result of this
the second round indeed the result of
the entire elections was ever in any
doubt Gonna Leave You with some pictures
now of the celebrations around his
residence here in Istanbul